so the first question why did you become
an entrepreneur and if anybody can you
know go first gee well I started my
entrepreneurial you know
unconventionally I actually dropped out
of high school when I was 16 so actually
what caused me to become an entrepreneur
was a little bit different my family was
going through little hardships I was
trying to go ahead and help out and you
know basically try it out my first job
and only job was trying out for
McDonald's and they rejected me so I
realized hey there's something called
the Internet and looked at what was
going on I mean just the the euphoria of
it and fell in love with the whole
online advertising space and you know
the beauty of the Internet is you don't
need the the stigma that's attached to
kind of business as it was probably
fifty years ago I mean you can be a 16
year old in a bedroom and start a
business that two years later you can
sell for forty million dollars and you
know that's probably wasn't possible 50
years ago so you know partly you know
survival helped me become an
entrepreneur but on top of that I love
building stuff out of nothing so
passionate about it as long as you have
in your DNA be successful so I became an
entrepreneur pretty much out of
necessity I had been working at a public
accounting firm been passed over for
partnership two times and I could see
that third was coming up and the only
reason was because I was woman and at
this point there were zero women in the
partnership across the world and that
just wasn't okay with me but I had
butted my head up against the glass
ceiling enough times and at this point
had enough visibility across the whole
firm to know that I wasn't personally
going to be able to change this
organization from the inside
so I left and turned around and offered
them my services for basically the exact
same thing that they would have had if I
had made partner within their structure
and asked them to pay me three times as
much
they agreed which was the amazing part
provided me a an office and let me keep
my administrative assistant for the
first six months and I was totally
billable from the very very first day
and that grew into a an organization
that had employees across the world and
and then you know kind of once you get
the bug it just kind of starts taking
over and so it's like well you know
there's a problem here I can solve it by
doing this and there's a problem there
and I can go solve that by doing this
and I love it yeah um so I guess the the
best answer that I can give is that I
didn't decide to become an entrepreneur
and and I mean that in two ways one I'm
actually not quite an entrepreneur I
don't really deserve to be called an
entrepreneur unlike all the other people
up here I've always sort of helped
entrepreneurs I joined the LinkedIn and
Facebook before we raised venture
funding before the companies were built
and so on so very very very early in
those companies but but short but always
sort of liked helping entrepreneurs they
used to call that being a venture
capitalist but that means something else
today I guess the so the second way in
which I mean that and at just really
amplifying what Carl just spoke to is I
think a lot of the time people who end
up being entrepreneurs don't really
exactly decide to become entrepreneurs
it's not like being an accountant where
you say you know I'm going to go out and
you know take a test and get a license
and go become an accountant you know I'm
going to go to entrepreneur school and
become an entrepreneur
it's a little bit more organic than that
a lot of the time in my experience and
it's just something that almost happens
to you or that you get the bug for like
you said usually because something's
broken that you want to fix or because
something doesn't exist that you think
should exist and you just decide you
know I'm going to do it and that can
take lots of different forms but I think
it's a more organic process than a lot
of other so-called career paths and I
actually never aspired to become an
entrepreneur and I was working as a
research scientist and I thoroughly
enjoyed that and so I never aspired to
become an entrepreneur working as a
manager or working in business in in the
first place but the thing that made an
impact on me was that I was actually
reading the specification for netscape
2.0 this would be some years ago
somebody may remember the browser
netscape but i was reading the whole
night and i was really taken by this and
it had an enormous impact on me so the
next day i actually quit my job and
started my first company and i had no
idea what kind of business idea I was
going to pursue I really didn't have
much of a plan but it was more this
incredible passion I felt for Internet I
could just sense that Internet was going
to be really really big I felt it was
too big thing a too big of a thing to
walk away from so that's actually why I
started so in the life of an
entrepreneur that you'll be all living a
life for an entrepreneur what is it you
like about the life of an entrepreneur
what is it you don't like about the path
that you have chosen
anybody ating just go to any order you
like yeah I guess what I love but is
yeah it's probably goes both ways I love
creating something out of nothing and
seeing that impact it's almost like you
can see it nurture and you can see the
positive result as quick as you can kind
of make it make it happen
the downside of being an entrepreneur is
that it's not as you know posh and
stable as a typical company where you
have enough things in place where you
don't have to worry about the revenue
you don't have to worry about
profitability you don't have to worry
about the individual thing so you end up
losing a few
is almost everyday so part of being a
start-up is you know you have your good
days and you have your bad days but you
know you fall down and get up and you
keep going so in the corporate world I
used to be called a workaholic and I'm a
pretty passionate person and when I'm on
a project or working on trying to get
something done I pretty much stay
focused on on that and and that used to
be considered a bad thing and when I
became an entrepreneur everybody just
started saying oh she's an entrepreneur
it's okay and um and and so I suddenly
became socially acceptable about the
fact that my work life in my personal
life had a very very blurry line
borderline if you're lucky yes yeah you
know the best thing about it is that
it's amazing and all consuming and
exhausting and crazy and the worst thing
about is that's amazing and all
consuming is all standing crazy it will
become your life if you're lucky and
you're and you're doing it well and
there's trade-offs in that but you know
I feel like the last 10 or so years of
my life are more or less this vortex of
non-stop startup Ness which is great I
wouldn't trade it for anything but it's
it I think it almost becomes an
either-or decision at some point if
you're lucky enough to be facing that
problem I think for me the biggest thing
is the dream you know that you're you
can allow yourself to dream you can
allow yourself to you know you're going
to create a company you're going to have
an impact over the world you know and
it's at the end of the day it's really
all up to you I think that's a fantastic
luxury that there's really no limitation
it's all about your capability your
creativity and your hard work that at
the end of the day hopefully you will be
able to accomplish what you set out to
do
things that all of us are talking about
is that we're doing it because we have
some passion about what what we're doing
and and with whom we're doing it and you
know one of the things that you'll hear
people give you advice about over and
over again is stay focus on your passion
and the reason is if you hate what
you're doing you won't be successful in
as an entrepreneur because it requires
too much extra effort and you have to
really love it too to make the
sacrifices that are necessary to be
successful you also have a little bit
crazy to enjoy the ups and downs of it
because there's a lot of ups there's a
lot of downs along the way but I think
it bikes yeah I think the other key
thing is that if you look at just how
the business world works you know big
companies get to run it but in a
start-up you get to change it and you
know if you look at you know companies
like Facebook Twitter and just social
media in general that's really
transpired the way we communicate big
companies are now falling onto that so I
think that's the the highlight of being
in Ashburn is when you can make that big
of an impact and if you're part of that
genre you can really go ahead and see
wow you know you're you're passionate
about it you're making a change in and
it's and it's a lot of fun I think
pretzels had that you have a phenomenal
luxury when you're an entrepreneur and
that is to pick the people you actually
are going to work with and I think that
really makes a big difference you know
one thing is to have this objective with
dream with desire but you can actually
work with people that are phenomenally
inspiring people that have fun to hang
out with people that you really care
about and regardless of where you want
to go with the company regardless what
you want to accomplish just a luxury
that everyday you will go to work you're
working people that fundamentally are
people do you like and you want to hang
out with I think that is a phenomenal
perk if you can put it that way so
that's a it's a great segue into the
next question and so we have some we
have both pure entrepreneurs and we have
some venture capital experience here so
you can answer it from either
perspective do you think it's better in
the construction of an entrepreneurial
company to partner to have a partner
with
someone that maybe has complementary
skills or vision or whatever or is it
better to go it alone it's a frustrating
answer but it depends on the person and
and you know it's there are people who
are absolutely solo creators who have a
very individual Drive and that's the way
they function there are people who you
know thrive and need a partner I think
you know the funny thing about about
startups is this whole thing is driven
by exceptions you know you can you can
create any rule you like you know oh you
know startups where the husband and wife
are founders together that always fails
well except for Cisco you know startups
I mean no matter what you pick there are
always exceptions so it's very hard to
generalize that of those things you know
I've been involved in companies where
there were kind of co-founders and a
founder and co-founders and just a
founder and I think all of them can work
the most important thing if you're
starting something yourself I think is
to ask yourself what's the right thing
for you and just like with a lot of the
other things that we've been talking
about it really should be a sort of
organic process I think if you sit down
and say all right today I need to go out
and find myself a co-founder that's
probably not going to succeed I think
it's all about you know a couple of ways
to look at it part of it is finding your
dream team and you don't eat there all
your co-founding employees and that's
really essential for any startup your
first five people make it or break it to
actually seeing if it's going to survive
first twenty people make it a see if
it's going to be a large company or not
and you know when you get to that
standpoint you got to go ahead and
realize who your right partners going to
be and partner can be beyond co-founder
it's really VC and you know just a short
plug for Stanford Stanford is actually
an investor in G wallets so I think we
got you know we picked the right
investors for the right reasons and
partly is because you know they can
actually add a tremendous value I mean
if you look at my first company I
actually took no funding whatsoever I
bootstrapped it mainly because nobody
wanted to fund me I was 16 17 18 so no
offense on that but
you know what I learned on the second
time around when I actually raised
venture capital is it matured me as an
entrepreneur it actually brought a
different perspective on how to grow a
large company how to actually sustain
certain things that you do international
expansion and so forth and picking that
right partner is key because if you put
the wrong one
you know VCS can either add a lot of
value or they can take a lot of value
out so that's the caveat no offense but
that's a that's the big formula into
finding the the right magic in that
partnership so you know the other part
is whether or not to do it alone or in a
team is also based on oh if you need
outside money you know how how are you
going to get it and in the venture world
one of the conventions is basically
never invest in a single entrepreneur
and the bottom line is if that
entrepreneur gets hit by a bus you know
what do we have so if you have at least
two people on a team then and one person
gets hit by a bus then at least
theoretically there's somebody to kind
of go forward and so typically by the
time you see them any entrepreneur
company coming forth to a venture
capital firm you'll see that they have
you know gotten to a point where they
have the least the outward appearance of
being a team right angels um kind of go
back and forth and and since I happen to
straddle both communities you know there
there are lots of angels that will fund
a single entrepreneur and then tell them
you have to go find you know other
co-founders but you know it depends on
how much money you need I think the
question would you you need a co-founder
or not perhaps the most important thing
is who you choose as co-founder and in
the heat of the moment or in the
excitement
or actually hatching an idea I think
that it's easy to find somebody that is
your soulmate right there and then right
they're all excited all let's do this
and you know and and they will worked up
about it but if you in a co-founder are
looking for somebody that can help you
build a company long term I think it's
very important to to dive below the
initial excitement right what is that
what is that person's long-term
contribution and what is that person's
long-term commitment and then
aspirations for the project and I when
I've seen some startups fail and succeed
I seen a lot of startups fail because
the the founding team was the wrong
founding team and the people and the
founding team did not have long-term
aligned objectives and perhaps one was
most wanted to work really hard for a
long time and the other one decided to
it was fun for a year or two but then
later the person was not willing to work
as hard anymore and if they didn't then
had a shareholder agreement that
regulated for whatever reason was going
to happen down the road creates a lot of
tension right then one person that was a
part of the founding team has a large
stake of the company but it's really
moving on to do something completely
different so that can create a lot of
issues and problems for for a company I
think I just just add on that I think
it's pretty crucial when you actually
find that person or find that your dream
team is to find the right DNA that has
the the hunger because partly even one
hiring you know my third company it's
it's you know you would assume I would
have the picket to draw and in hiring
the best talent and fortunately there is
that pool there but it's really really
hard when you can look someone in the
eye and said is this person hungry or is
this person just expecting a great
outcome because any startup regardless
of it doesn't guarantee an outcome and
it's really really hard to go ahead and
find out that the consensus DNA is going
to go ahead and do what it takes to make
the eggs that happen or make the
positive outcome happen and probably one
percent of the people out interview I
can see that hunger ninety nine percent
just don't have it so it's really
finding that one percent especially in
that first five employees especially
the first 20 employees because if you
don't you're going to set yourself up
for disappointment and failures so this
is one of one of the questions that I
personally can relate to have you ever
experienced a black day now I describe a
black day is all despair and no hope and
so if you have could you tell us about
it share the you know kind of
anecdotally share it with us and then
tell us you know how you dealt with it
internally because it's certainly
difficult and how did you deal with it
with your company so I think everybody
probably has a story it may not but I
think for any successful entrees because
it grounds you and they also teach you a
lot that's something that something's
cooler had more than one I've had my
fair share
probably more than more than I wanted
but I think that the primary one that
sticks to mind was I was 16 six months
into my business dropped out of high
school was doing two or three hundred
thousand dollars a month in revenue
highly profitable and started hiring the
right people and I didn't have any
formal contracts in place with the
primary engineer person that I had that
was managing that the technology and I
just got a threat from them that if I
did not give him a third of the company
they would shut me down and again 16 and
a half years old did not have any idea
so I was trying to play poker and
obviously didn't work in my favor and
they actually did shut me down and
obviously when you're under funded you
don't have a board you're 16 nobody's in
truly take you seriously so imagine all
the odds against you and imagine
completely being out of business for a
full week so imagine no Facebook for a
week
imagine your email not working for a
week no imagine whatever service you're
running is gone from the internet and
the internet 24/7 business right so that
happened and it took me a week to go to
go ahead and recover from that until I
recovered from the servers until I got
the right people to turn them back on
and you know as a mess it was a mess and
what I realized is that there's a couple
things you got to do number one never
keep yourself vulnerable if you're an
entrepreneur always have a back-up plan
always have
else that's going to have your back or
you better make sure you have that skill
set on yourself because if you don't
you're going to have situations like
this number two always surround yourself
around people that want to make you win
and see you win and you know make sure
you have the right rockstars with you
because if you don't have those right
people you're going to have you know so
many of these horror stories over and
over and you know I learned a lot from
that and I wasn't cheap on employees I
wasn't cheap on any of the structures I
needed to do from there on and you know
a year and two months after that point
is actually when I sold a company for 40
million dollars so yeah that was
probably the most black day of any
teenagers life that you can imagine but
you know it ended up becoming a positive
outcome because I learned a lot from it
and a lot of it you know from at least
from my entrepreneurial journey it came
from making these mistakes and actually
seeing these disappointments come to
life because you know they ground you
and they teach you a lot and they
prepare you for for the future so I
think there's probably two kinds of
black days there's the black days which
mark defined as days where there's truly
all despair and no hope and we've all
had those days in our lives in different
ways you know this is just part of life
so these things happen I think with
startups in my experience it usually
takes one of two forms either you've had
some great momentum and it suddenly
stopped or it's just slowed down
dramatically and you don't see how
you're going to find your way back out
of that or a people issue and you know
those take all kinds of forms but
there's also a lot of black days where
there actually is some hope in there if
you look at it closely and so in terms
of how you deal with it
I think trying to find that that that
hope and you know trying to find the
kernel of what's going to enable you to
turn this around whether it's something
specific and tactical or something
emotional is really important you know
personal example of that which has been
talked about a lot is when we launched
the news feed at Facebook in the fall of
2006 and we had a product that we had a
lot of conviction around and felt was a
great product
which was a great product we just did a
really really incredibly terrible job of
actually launching it and preparing
people for it or not preparing people
for it and the reaction was you know
unbelievable
we had 10% of the user base actively
protesting against us 10% of the user
base a million people actively
protesting we got a phone call from the
Palo Alto Police Department saying turn
it off right now because there's going
to be a protest rally in downtown Palo
Alto on Monday and we can't wait on the
infrastructure to support a protest
rally in this city so you have to stop
it
camera crews coming up the windows of
the office peering into the office to
you know try to get pictures of people
just a really unbelievable amount of you
know bad feeling and pressure coming
from the entire outside world but what
was so meaningful about that moment for
me was that was the moment when I fully
understood for the first time just how
important this was to people that people
cared about this so much that they would
get this upset about it in large numbers
so my god this is there's something
going on here which is really really
rare and really special and and we have
a problem that we need to deal with but
you know underneath that all there's
something very powerful here that we can
harness you know if we do it in the
right way so there are situations in
life whether in your startup or in the
rest of your life where things are just
bad and there and there just is no
nothing you can do about it but get
through it but a lot of times there's
actually something more in those
situations so I'd encourage everybody to
at least ask the question is is there
something else to this story I'd
actually like to answer the question in
a slightly different way I'm a little
bit older than most of the other
panelists so I think I've had probably
more black days but what's gotten me
through them is that I picked up the
phone and and talk to an advisor and in
the advice
help me put the situation in perspective
and and one of the attributes about a
really bad black day is the reason why
we call it black is that things went
from gray to black the black days
they're really black yeah yeah I mean I
mean all you can see is bad and negative
and and your normal personality of
positive and seeing the silver lining
and not suddenly just left your body and
in it was that ability to reach out and
and have perspective brought back in and
it's amazing when I look back through my
life and I look at those black days it
was literally less than 24 hours before
I was able to reframe that as this is
when the universe changed rather than
this is a black day and I've now gotten
to the point where when I hit black days
I'm like oh the universe is about to
change okay and and I actually now try
to very actively be that special advisor
for our portfolio companies and um I I
hope I'm the one that when they get in
trouble that I'm the one that they call
yeah I think yeah one example of black
day for me would be a complete Rd
dead-end so this was this fingerprint
research company that I started Genki so
this was a very ambitious projects and
initially we thought it was going to be
fairly easy we're going to revolutionize
how fingerprint matching algorithms were
done but it turned out to be much much
harder than we thought and only way we
actually found a textbook saying that
this was actually not possible this was
theoretically an exciting idea but in
practices wouldn't work and but we of
course that made it more excited than we
wanted to to go on
but as time goes moving on we were
really not getting any progress and and
and he had spent I think three and a
half years and I spent several millions
in funding this and it was to the point
when the engineers on a team they didn't
believe it anymore and everyone else was
questioning whether it was possible to
move forward and I had a wake up call
one day when one of my friends there at
which I trust really well said yeah
you're so stubborn why is it that
everyone else in the world believes that
this is impossible even your engineers
working R&D team and still you believe
that this is doable you know and then I
started to ask myself am i delusional am
i completely irrational am I just trying
to pursue a dream that is really not
ever going to happen and that was a
really tough moment for me and I was
really mulling this over and I was
thinking the only rational thing
actually is to throw in the towel right
everyone around me told me that that was
going to be the case but the thing that
made me not throw in the towel was that
when I was really feeling and really
thinking through it deeply I realized
that if I threw in the towel now I would
never be able to forgive myself I always
going to continue in my life asking what
if I didn't throw in the towel and when
I came to that realization I decided
that you know whatever it takes okay I
set it aside this amount of money and
whatever it takes dissing on the money
I'm able to set aside and I'm going to
go all the way all the way to the
absolute point where there's no hope
whatsoever that this is is going to be
successful and then I'm willing to throw
in the towel but I know for sure that I
have done everything I can and after
that it wasn't too black anymore because
I know that I kind of felt good that I
had a car my plan and what happened was
that we actually had had to get a
completely new R&D team so I moved the
whole or India to the US and slowly adds
and and and secretly we were able to
turn around and we were able to get the
breakthroughs that we were hoping for
three years later did you write your
point like all right I've done
everything I can that's it I'm throwing
in the towel I was were close at that
point right I decided that I decided
okay whatever it takes this is the money
that I'm willing to spend right this is
the this is how far I'm willing to push
it and I was thinking about selling lots
of things I had and whatever you know
I'm willing to bring it to this point
and once I had that main that mental
decision I was kind of ready to go and
then it wasn't that black anymore
I think the flip side of that is I think
a lot of people when they walk into what
they want to do they walk in with fear
and they walking with failure so you
know they're basically saying okay I got
this great idea I want to go and work on
it and then they're spending 80 to 90
percent of the energy on the fact that
it's in a fail already versus at ten
percent okay maybe it won't fail right
so I think it's great when you can go
and set aside okay this is my plan and
this is my point of how far I'm gonna
take it and I'm gonna give it my all I'm
going to spend that 100% of my time in
making it happen the flip side of that
is that when you even when you haven't
even started it when you have nothing to
even go ahead and and and and do it and
you're consuming yourself with all this
negative energy where you're like oh my
god am I gonna fail and if I fail my
families and I think this my friends are
gonna think this in right I think that's
really where when you're starting off as
an entrepreneur you had a clear you know
clear your head on that and just walk in
that failure is not an option and you're
gonna give it all your all from day one
I think that's one of the big
characteristics of her a really
successful entrepreneur is that they
actually never recognized that they
could fail it's part stubborn part
ambition yeah yeah I have a feeling I
have a feeling that Jordan was never
actually gonna reach that point where he
said you know what I've done it I know
it was there was no money left you know
there was no nothing
right I would go raise some more money
no no my money every great entrepreneur
that I've ever worked with when they hit
that point somehow managed to go find
exactly you know just to because I maybe
I don't know if I've seen more black
days anybody else but boy I've seen my
share and over time I've actually come
to look at them as opportunities
leadership opportunities you know you
can you know everybody looks at the bet
you the leader of the company and
everybody's down and you know they're
looking at you and and you're down but
it's an opportunity to say let's do
something let's take action let's you
know create a plan and if you prevail
you actually build tremendous bonds in
that leadership team and the team inside
the company so you know if you can kind
of step out of the blackness just for a
moment and say is there an opportunity
here there really actually is I mean
that's that's kind of one of the things
I've seen
but keying off of Carol's comment the
next question I had was what are the
characteristics of an entrepreneur and
what other I mean there's many I mean I
certainly have teach this the subject
matter and I've come up with lists of
2030 you know different words that did
it what do you think of the
characteristics that are that are
central to the to the character of an
entrepreneur all right I'll start so I
think the details actually vary a little
bit by market but to abstract out from
that to what some of we've all been
talking about I think that the most
important thing is that it's something
that comes from passion for whatever it
is that you're doing whatever it is
you're building whatever it is you're
making whatever problem it is you're
solving whatever new thing it is you're
bringing into the world that can
manifest itself in lots of different
ways there are a few people out there
for whom that passion is actually the
act of entrepreneurship and those are
people who I think generally are called
serial entrepreneurs but for those
people it really is like
entrepreneurship itself is the thing
that they're
passionate about some people are like
that a lot of people were great
entrepreneurs aren't really like that
and don't even necessarily sort of
self-identify as entrepreneurs and just
self-identify as yeah I'm doing this
thing you know it's just this thing that
that I not that even that I want to do
is just like yet this is just what I do
I do this I have to do this and so I do
think the details vary a little bit by
market but the best abstraction that I
can or the best example template that I
can think of for that particularly for
the areas that I focus on is Martin
Luther that's sort of the template that
I always hold up for somebody who's a
great entrepreneur the reason that I say
Martin Luther in particular is you need
to sort of be you know just a little bit
crazy completely convicted that you know
your your idea and your way is the way
the world needs to go but not sort of to
the point of irrationality and
self-destruction you know there's a
difference between somebody who's an
evangelist and and a and a creator and
somebody who's a martyr and you know I
hear people talk about you know Joan of
Arc as an entrepreneurial architect
sometimes I would argue that's a little
too much martyrdom and a little too
little impact so you know getting the
balance on that right is very tricky but
it's that just conviction that's
completely transcendent to everything
and is just something that the person
does must do it's just you know it is
what it is that's sort of the the
architect in my in thei archetype in my
mind I think one character is that you
got a swallow really really hard is you
got a embrace rejection and sometimes
the hardest thing to do as a human being
but if you can swallow it and understand
how to you know deal with it you're
going to probably solve 80% of your
problems and I mean if you just look at
my career path
nobody wanted to fund me at a click
agents I was doing millions of dollars
in revenue and millions of dollars in
profit but nobody wanted to fund me
because I wasn't part of the dot-com
you know euphoria and in the way things
looked at least back in the heyday
and then at blue lithium I had three
different venture capitalists pull away
from doing a deal with me at the last
minute so imagine like doing high fives
with your employees and realizing oh
we're going to get millions of dollars
in for the company and then getting it
pulled I even had one very famous
venture firm in the valley told me that
I was going to miserably fail at blue
lithium and that I should listen to them
and you know divert my attention into
something that's actually in a work so
and I wonder where he's now but I'd love
to have a drink with them but you know
if you look at that and then just kind
of look at even the you know other
industries you know look at garment that
you know the founder that company tried
88 times till he got an investor to
actually say yes and then if you look at
JK Rowling as an author the most
respected most least a billion-dollar
billionaire author and she got rejected
seven times from her first book so all
that comes down to the human nature of
realizing what your pain tolerance is
for embracing rejection and so long as
you can grow a thick skin drown out the
noise and focus on that objective
I mean you will prevail I think I think
yeah the way I look at an entrepreneur
is really that entrepreneurship is
really a way to express yourself in the
same way an artist is creating or
painting a painting or a composer writes
music I think fundamentally an
entrepreneur creates a company that's a
great organization in a way to express
himself or herself and so there's an
underlying passion and it's underlying
desire to contribute in some way to get
their voice heard to to to to add to the
world or make the world in in that tiny
way a little better and I think the
preps are three qualities that I would
on the top of my head think of that is
important qualities I think one is that
you are very optimistic you know if you
have if you see the world through an
Steve lens every person you meet is a
potential partner or an employee or a
purse or a client right if you have a
negative perspective every person you
meet is a competitor or some or there's
an obstacle towards your success so have
that positive mindset I think it's
hugely important because then you see
the opportunities that you will that
that comes your way that your person
didn't even think about initially the
second one is the same thing as the
genius not amount that ability to absorb
rejections that be able to absorb
disappointments setbacks because it is
going to be a long way it is going to be
away with a lot of setbacks and to to
withstand that I think it's essential to
be successful as an entrepreneur
approach this last thing is a way to
impact people around you because an edge
and as an entrepreneur typically you you
have to create a phenomenal team around
you for the company to be successful and
you don't need to be the light of the
party you don't need to have phenomenal
people skills but at least there's
something with you that that you are
able to inspire other people perhaps
you're the best developer that you were
extremely passionate about what you do
welcome you have this strong conviction
that other people see they like and they
want to follow you so I think there is
an element of having ability to
influence and attract and inspire other
people as a key ingredients in that so
being positive absorbing rejections and
and affecting people in in one way or
another
Carolee everything they had the only
thing I want to just add in this
conversation is in in my mind there is a
gigantic difference between an inventor
and an entrepreneur and and in Silicon
Valley we tend to blend the two and and
I think that's a big mistake there are
lots of people who can create
interesting technologies
but they can't deliver and and so for me
the Entrepreneurship part shows up in
their ability to deliver and and and
that's a very vague term but anybody
it's been an entrepreneur will
understand that that is where the rubber
meets the road it's a great point I
think a lot of where that delivery
happens just as Yorn said is around
people people people people the people
you can rally to work with you and help
you the people who you can inspire who
are going to be your customers or your
users or your other constituents the
people you're going to inspire to invest
in you exactly that that ability to not
just create something but to inspire
others with with your creation I think
it's the thing that propels you forward
from an initial ideation to actually
succeeding I think entrepreneurship is
kind of like it's like an art and
there's probably three stages of it and
I mean this in wholeheartedly there's
probably the first stage where you're
the creator and you're the inventor and
you're trying to prove of concept the
second stage is you're the manager
you're actually trying to go ahead and
scale the company actually trying to
build you're actually trying to go ahead
and prosper in that regard and the last
part is you're the executor you're
actually executing against a potential
outcome and that itself is a different
strategy so all three require a
completely different approach and it's
up to you as an entrepreneur to see if
you can mold yourself as a company grows
so you know exactly how to go ahead and
act because you can't act like the
Creator when you already had a company
that's already doing a hundred million
dollars in revenue and you're trying to
go ahead and have a potential exit you
got to be a completely different CEO so
partly it's it's it's it's you know the
problem that I see in most entrepreneurs
is that they get way too emotional with
certain things whether that is owning
certain amounts or controlling certain
amounts but I think the best thing about
being an entrepreneur is being able to
adapt to the different changes that
you're able to do in the various stages
of entrepreneurism the other hand though
I want to make sure that people are
clear about the fact that
entrepreneur does not necessarily mean
founder I mean there are lots of people
that were extraordinarily
entrepreneurial at Google or at Intuit
or at Cisco and at Yahoo I mean pick the
company I mean being entrepreneurial is
a state of mind it it isn't you know the
fact that you're the the founder have
you in this character issue how do you
feel about you know risk seeking risk
avoidance kind of thing that would a lot
of people describe entrepreneurs as as
risk seeking do you how would you how
would you comment on that
so I think your ability to live in a
risky environment is pretty important as
an entrepreneur you know that the whole
concept of you know can you sleep at
night becomes a big one and and if
you're going to put your health at risk
being an entrepreneur probably isn't the
right thing for for you and you know
there are times in your life where you
can't afford to take a risk you have too
many other individuals in your life that
are depending on you and and so I think
there's some you know kind of reality
checks that you need to have about your
risk levels having said that most of the
entrepreneurs that have been incredibly
successful are the ones who took risks
at extremely inappropriate times in
their lives and and so who Ted have
Matt's point you set a rule down and
somebody's going to think of an
exception to it so but but risk being
willing to live with risk is a big one
that's a big distinction the distinction
between being okay living with risk
being risk tolerant
and being risk-seeking yeah you know I
think it's it's kind of crazy to be risk
seeking per se I think great
entrepreneurs tend to be changed seeking
and when you're trying to change things
that risk is inherently a part of the
process you have to be ok with that but
people who sort of seek out risk for the
sake of seeking out risk maybe you'll
get lucky
um but that doesn't seem like the you
know the way to make things happen to me
actually you know in many cases I think
especially when they're starting up the
company you don't see the risk oh
absolutely I mean you're so clear about
your vision of the future exactly that
the 2jg spike failure isn't an option
reminded by the vision right yeah yeah
um so yeah but I agree with that you
know because a lot of times when you
talk about entrepreneurship a lot of
people still talk about risk or taking
risk and there is something with that
that rubs me the wrong way because I
don't think necessarily entrepreneurs
are taking risk at least I don't look at
myself as taking risk on the contrary I
feel that I continuously try to minimize
risk but what I do try to do is pursue
opportunities I see but I don't look at
myself as a risk taker I'm willing to
leave a risk I willing to tolerate or to
leverage risk
Ram I am NOT a risk taker I minimize
risk for what we ever ability and
capable over doing you know so it's more
I think that's a big distinction but in
reality the the fact that you're willing
to operate without a net
yeah my definition I think I moved you
into the risk yeah perhaps bit more risk
tolerant once you say that you are a
risk I feel that you you're stepping
over over a line that I'm not
comfortable associating myself right
well I also think there's two types of
risks that entrepreneurs take I mean
there's also two types of entrepreneurs
um you know there's a type of
entrepreneur
so I'm gonna go with the crazy idea and
nobody's done it before and I'm gonna
try to go ahead and prove myself right I
love those I'm not one of those uh
I'm one of the I'm on the second
category which is basically saying okay
I recognize that there's enough people
doing this and I understand this may be
a crowded space but I'm going to copy
exactly what they're doing but I'm gonna
go ahead and catch up to them by
executing them better and then I'm going
to innovate and if you kind of think
about that that's how majority of all
the successful companies in Silicon
Valley have actually started I mean if
you look at you know kind of Friendster
in my space you know myspace was just
copying Friendster but it could scale
right and then if you kind of look at
MySpace and Facebook I mean Facebook
yeah is very different now
but it had the same functionalities at a
certain point too and you know that's
really where I think the my
recommendation to entrepreneurs is that
don't put yourself I mean again I know
you love the first category but I kind
of fear that if people try to go ahead
and prove something that haven't been
proven before you're walking into a room
that isn't already disqualified yeah so
you know that's some some that happens
with depending on industry so I mean for
instance the area that we've made the
most amount of money is in medical
devices varna and and the reason why our
companies have been successful and have
made us a lot of money is because they
did something totally new and different
and I like that too yeah
so I mean you know that sure there's
room for both sure but I think there's
all I'm saying is there's a lot of risk
in putting something in a category that
hasn't been proven I mean just based on
enough data that supports you know new
investments that haven't been proven
versus going after a category that is
already out there and you're competing
against it there's always going to be a
leader there's always going to be an
incumbent that maybe that's just the
nature of business all I'm saying is
that at least for me as an entrepreneur
I reside in the latter where I'm not
going to take that risk of coming up
with something completely different and
you know be left kind of you know cold
shoulders in the marketplace versus kind
of going in with it and you know
replicating something and then
innovating it
I I would execute them and you know
after I've reached a certain point join
but I think when it comes to risk
I sometimes I'm not sure if I'm
understand all the discussion area
because what are you risking right
there's an under underlying assumption
that there's something specific that
you're risking and I think that people
have different aspects of what is
worthwhile risking what this worthwhile
not risking right so the so if you don't
have a good understanding of what you're
risking that the discussion becomes very
abstract too right and I the way I look
at it is that you you have a certain
amount of time on this planet tomorrow
you can be hit by a truck and why do I
want to live my life doing something
that I don't feel fulfilled with that's
a big risk that you live the whole life
and being miserable right so so it
depends a little bit on what it is that
you really want to do and what you are
willing to risk and in that perspective
I think yeah I understand that risk is a
sociable entrepreneurship but I don't
like the notion risk is put on a
entrepreneur saying that this person is
a risk taker let me move to one more
issue of this entrepreneurial character
that I think is interesting to discuss
you know in my thinking over the years
about what motivates entrepreneurs I've
kind of come with three categories
change the world build a great company
get rich so yeah so so what is the I
think all three is fine but some people
are driven more by one than by others so
how would you describe you know those
three words for yourselves in terms of
how you how do you kind of slot yourself
or profile yourself relative to those
things do you think those are relevant
to entrepreneurial motivation I mean I
would say I mean I I never did anything
for the money and I think that anybody
that walks into an entrepreneurship
endeavor to get rich is already failed
and I mean monetary exits cash that you
make is really comes after all the hard
work and you can't even think about that
from day one and if the minute you do
you're going to start making you know
short term decisions that are going to
go ahead and affect your business
decisions that you should be making so
for me it's always been about being
successful and improving myself that I
can do it again and that I know the
formula and so long as I know the
formula I want to challenge myself for
the next opportunity and you know sure
the money that comes along it's like
keeping score well that's about it yeah
I think the change the world idea or
variance on that like for me the way I
would articulate it personally is sort
of you know be involved with the most
interesting things I can be involved
with is that's it and all the best
entrepreneurs I know tend to look at the
building of a great company and the
making of a lot of money as means to the
end of accomplishing the goal that
they're trying to accomplish you know
the idea that I want this to be
structured as a company because a
company is the best vehicle to
accomplish what it is that I'm trying to
accomplish if there were a better
vehicle I would use that other vehicle
instead but this is the best vehicle so
that's what I'm going to do that's the
mentality that resonates most with me
and I think you know can get you to the
biggest and most exciting places I think
changing the world is such a big term
but I think definitely there is a part
of me that trips try to contribute
somehow a mildly the way so I think and
the reason why I think that is important
because I think everyone looking for
some kind of meaning or purpose with
what you do that you actually see that
what you do has a positive effect and
that I think is an important part of my
drive in addition to that I think it is
going back to a little further it
working with people that you really care
about working with people that you're
really passionate about and indirectly
whether it's really building an
organization that you take pride in so
you know I think that the kind of the
core motivation and where the company is
in its growth process is going to
motivate where the money sources are
coming from
and so if you're trying to change the
world but there's no clear path to
making money the type of investor that
you're going to attract is going to be
very different than one that you come in
and say you know here's here's the plan
I'm going to do this this is going to
happen and and you're going to get your
money back in three years at you know X
percentage not having heard that speech
a lot of time I'd never believed it but
but the point is that it it attracts a
different type of investor and and so
part of the game and one of the things
that craters any startup is not being
properly capitalized and so part of the
game is figuring out where are the right
pockets of of money for your startup and
I think I think you need to understand
when do you need to attract money
because of passion when do you need to
attract money out of greed and and where
do you need to attract money out of the
philosophy of building a bigger stronger
company one of the questions I think is
generally interest certainly to the
students that I teach is where do great
ideas great insights come from and if
you're willing to share what's hot now
I would say social gaming and social
media is probably from a sector probably
one of the interesting sectors that that
I see right now
I mean handsome in it but in terms of
ideas and execution I mean part of my
philosophy is that idea when you get it
is 1% of the journey 99 percent of it is
all execution so I know a lot of people
that get wound up because they see a hot
idea or a hot sector and you know they
basically I mean I even get crazy email
saying hey I have the next trillion
dollar idea I don't even know if that
idea exists but still in terms of
people's mindset they think this idea is
to make them rich or this idea is it
that's it that's that's 1% right there
you know 99% of how you actually ask you
from starting a company making it into
something and going through the ups and
downs that you're gonna have to go
through is really the outcome that you
should focus on yeah I refuse to even
answer the question because it's not
what anybody should be thinking about if
they're thinking about starting
something you need to be thinking about
you know what you wish were hot tomorrow
not what's hot now the you know my job
is to spot what's hot now before anybody
else spots what's hot now but that's a
different topic that's being a venture
capitalist
you know the entrepreneurs job is to do
the thing that they want to do and so I
wouldn't worry about what's hot now
actually the only the only extent to
which I'd worry about what's hot now is
if you really want to do something and
you look and you say you know this is
really hot right now that's probably a
bad sign but beyond that just forget it
don't don't don't you know don't look at
it as a positive or negative just ignore
it just ignore everything just do do
what you want to do I was strongly
support for yours Matt I I totally agree
and I I think that sometimes there's a
little bit of a fever that we are
chasing what is hot you know and and and
that I think that is a big mistake you
do that you try to come up with
something that is hot you know it must
be something that you're passionate
about it must be something that you you
you really see that this will have an
impact that this will really create
value and and where to look
I you know I have no idea really but I
love internet I think Internet's is
fantastic and particularly when you
think about combining that with mobile
phones and I think that some people say
that all the innovation on the Internet
is done some people say that social
media and and social network is the last
big innovation on the Internet
I don't think that's true whatsoever I
mean we are the first generation I grew
up with computers Internet has just come
up
in in late in the last few years
social media didn't come a history until
one one year ago so within that space
they're just phenomenal and phenomenal
opportunities to convene innovative
products and services and I'm sure that
we just scratch the surface or what what
we pop what we're going to see going
forward there are so many problems in
the world and you know kind of the core
areas that tend to trigger people's
passion is that they're trying to solve
a problem or they're fantasizing a
different world so you know the current
state of the transportation industry
drives me nuts anybody can do beam me up
Scotty I'm like so there you know I'm
concerned about health and I know that
there are like several core things that
I need to do exercise and sleep and and
what I eat are the three you know big
things that will impact my health so you
know anybody that can make that easier
and simpler and you know I can eat
anything I want never put on a pound
would be fabulous all right you know you
could I mean you start working through
you know what's wrong in the world where
the big problems where the big trends I
mean we have a huge bunch of people that
are crossing the 5th
your old line and the world is different
when you're 50 and and so how do we meet
those needs we have a younger generation
that is moving into a global world not a
village world how does that impact I
mean pick an area and and you can
discover that there are problems in the
minute you discovered the problems you
start fantasizing about how to solve it
and bingo you know people talk about
this idea of changing the world a lot I
think a lot of the times what they
really mean is is changing your world
you know the really great things that
people create and build and turn into
big companies I think they usually come
from very personal places and so you
know you have to sort of find what's
personal for you and what is about your
life that you want to change and I think
it could be subtle but in lots of ways
that extension is is is the driver for
people when you start thinking about
problems at sort of grand levels of
abstraction I think you risk getting
into sort of dangerously unemotional
territory this is hard right it's really
hard to do this you have to really
really really want to do this all day
and all night
seven days a week for the next assume
it's going to take 20 years you know and
completely disrupt and interfere with
and screw up the rest of your life so it
better be really really really really
personal so it's great to want to change
the world but I think a lot of times
when people talk about changing the
world they're really talking about
changing themselves and changing their
role and changing the world around them
and that may sound selfish but you know
emotions are important when we when I
when I talk about in class I always talk
use a word Authentics that there's an
authenticity yeah a great ideas come
from personal experience the ability to
be unhappy with something see an
opportunity to change it and apply that
and then that's you know that yields
ideas and what's hot now
in which I you know I always ask it's a
kind of like the Groucho Marx quote
which is you know who'd want to be a
member of a club that would have me and
you know what's hot now if I knew that I
would be sitting you know I'd be out
doing it instead of it sitting here
talking about it right I want to make
sure that at least I'm communicating is
that entrepreneurship is not limited to
technology entrepreneurship happens in
all walks of life and in all business
segments and there are investors that
will support that we happen to have a
particularly high concentration of
technology-based investors here in
Silicon Valley but that doesn't mean
that that is the world and yeah they
build Starbucks on a great cup of coffee
and there's nothing good about let's we
have five minutes left let's open it up
and see if there's any questions from
the audience for all or any particular
panelists and it's about surrounding
yourself by great people when you go
back sort of to startup mode
you know how much kind of credibility
behind you not many people know you have
this what you think is a great idea
how do you actually hire these players
like what are some practical sort of
steps from the knowledge you know now of
how you would go out and try to
influence some people to come on board
well there's there's probably there's
two categories of rock stars there's the
first category of the founding employees
sweat equity rock star and then secondly
the rock stars you higher out of second
stage of the company I think you're
asking about the primary stage and just
a quick story on my side is than when I
started blue lithium I actually found a
company in Belarus of all places through
the internet and you know they had a
great technology
I actually went down there visited them
and there were just scrappy
entrepreneurs building code in you know
an apartment building you know next to
about 18 different computers and I love
that I love the the scrappiness the
bootstrap nests and you know when I
looked him in the eye and said what do
you want for your company and they
basically said a half a million dollars
and I said okay how about if I can give
you more than that and when I can go
ahead and what well in a different way
and the way was you know for them to buy
into my vision of what I wanted to
create and you know you gotta understand
when you're trying to look for that
rupture you got to have people that want
to take that risk and when they take
that risk they're going to go ahead and
you know work their ass off for that and
when they do they'll deliver it and that
that risk were they ended up taking a
stake in my company rather than sold
wallpaper rather than a half a million
dollars
three years later ended up becoming 15
million dollars for them so when you
look at it from that context there are
enough people out there that are hungry
it's not that many but there's enough
out there and when you can find them you
know everybody's after the same journey
and everybody's after the same goal
amplify and keep it a little bit
different view on is there's lots of
different ways to be hungry and some of
the ways to be hungry can be very
destructive for your company some of the
ways for people to be hungry can be
incredibly powerful for your company I
think you really want to find people not
who are low eco which is what people
always talk about but rather who have a
strong ego in a desire to sublimate that
completely into what it is that the
company is doing which is a different
thing but is very important distinction
so how do you do that
you have to be really careful to find
people who are you know no one will ever
be as deeply passionate about what the
company is making is the founder of
perhaps but you need to find people who
are really really passionate about what
the company is doing as opposed to the
fact that the company is hot or the
company is you know in an interesting
space or the company has funding from
good investors or whatever that's hard
to do I think there's some tactical ways
you can do it you know at some of the
companies I've been involved with we've
had people take title deflation on
coming into the company which is it
somewhat contrarian thing a lot of
management theorists say that's a very
bad thing to do but actually I think
it's very good litmus test for why is
this person here why are they coming
here there's lots of other ways you can
do that too but the those subtle
differences can have a huge impact on
how things go I think we're actually a
little past our time but let me say
thank you to all the panelists I assume
that some of you'll be available for
some people would come over and say
hello to afterwards thank you very much